[Applause]
um
look my man my man uh sean king
talcum x shout outs
um he he's out here you know sean king's
been out here he's been uh
very vocal during this time with george
floyd and i haven't been very at all
critical with him because i think that
most have been uh most of us have been
aligned with the things that he's been
fighting for yeah
um but just like sean king does he gonna
have to go
and get out of pocket you know you're
gonna have to
you're gonna have to get out of pocket
take it out of pocket like a
handkerchief
a white handkerchief you know what i'm
saying so talcomag
said and this is the quote yes i think
the statues of the white europe
european they claim is jesus should also
come down
they're a form of white supremacy always
have been
in the bible the family of jesus wanted
to hide
and blend in guess where they went egypt
not denmark tear them down
wow now
you know what here's a ding
they didn't go to denmark because they
didn't know denmark existed one
obviously
uh two he just had sandals
freezing in denmark you can't go through
that weather i mean he's just not built
for sandal you know denmark right i
don't think that was even on the table
yes second of all walking on water is
easy when it's made out of ice he
wouldn't even be special
right like if denmark is doing actually
third of all
people take so many liberties with jesus
just make them black what's the big
[ __ ] deal you go to asia
jesus is asian you go to parts of africa
you go to ethiopia
my man was telling us uh uh last week
abba was telling us last week when he
grew up going to church in ethiopia
he's music but when he was going to go
into any church jesus was black
you never see you want your god to look
like you if he's flesh
you want him to look like you yo so just
make him black
nobody care do you think jesus really
had abs
jesus has abs in every rendition of i
haven't met a single middle eastern
person with apps in my entire life
not a single one has absolutely awesome
can you name one no but here's bob i was
going to say
jesus there's a lot of dark-skinned
black jesus hanging up in black people's
houses in america
if jesus went to egypt i the egyptians i
know aren't dark-skinned black people
they look more middle eastern oh yeah
egyptians are middle eastern
romney look middle eastern everybody on
a show when you went to egypt look
middle eastern
absolutely if you hide in egypt it's
probably because you look middle eastern
or dark is dark skinned black jesus a
problem
yo just make ex that's a great point so
but make him put jesus in blackface
blackface him
yes blackface jesus give him an afro
give him cornrows who gives a [ __ ]
change his name changes it to what i
don't know
black jesus
jesus
no not jesus jesus the jesus christ
no but for real it's like stop it with
this tear down the statue [ __ ]
it's so stupid i mean crazy they were
he's accusing someone of presenting a
different race than they are
that's that crazy that is so crazy that
is so
crazy that sean king is accusing someone
presenting themselves as a different
race
than they are i mean what a disgusting
thing it's vile
it is absolutely vile it's just like
you're a leo man how do you
you're an imposter yeah how do you live
with yourself as an imposter
i don't know how could you possibly be a
different race than you
actually are where do you go to blend in
in
hbcu
where would you dude you go to an hbcu
is no different than
white jesus going to egypt that's
blended so shut the [ __ ] up
in atlanta and bankhead or buckhead
which one of those two
i didn't even know i'm just curious i
really hope black people
like if you want jesus to be black by
all means
black them up black
real talk do it whatever you want to do
just do it i don't think listen mark
you're the most christian person here
would you give a flying [ __ ]
take him off the cross put him on a hoop
i don't give a [ __ ] have a [ __ ]
dunkin vince carter style i don't care
make him vince carter
real talk bro go for it yeah but there
wasn't basketball back then who cares
neither there wasn't denmark either
there wasn't denmark that story's been
rewritten a million times
really [ __ ] happened it's all fake
guess what
jesus wasn't even christian he was
[ __ ] jewish
that's gonna break your heart when you
find that out huh
that guy had a message on his front door
okay he was taking saturdays off sammy
davis jr more like jesus than any black
person i know huh
explain it oh he's black and jewish yes
black and jewish like kid cuddy
okay cut he's jewish i think like drake
great
there we go yeah oh drake is black and
jewish but doesn't he have that song
kid cutting this on like black and
dreidel black andre
no that's not him that's where's
khalifa's middle eastern bro yeah
khalifa khalifa come on
[ __ ] train black and traitor
look so all i'm trying to say is like
stop it with that [ __ ] this
this [ __ ] statue says drive me crazy
would they want to switch to columbus
statue
do we i want to tell you something
because we were doing research when we
did our statues piece about the columbus
statue you know what's hilarious
you know who also wanted the columbus
statues taken down
columbus the kkk